in all of the chaos regarding the
nomination of judge brett kavanaugh we
should remember
one simple fact if kavanaugh wore
pro-choice
he would have been confirmed with 100
votes he's clearly not
an advocate for abortion but democrats
didn't have the votes to stop him
so instead democrats decided to slander
him as a gang rapist
remember democratic opposition to
kavanaugh started not
with christine blasey ford but with
women in handmaid's tale outfits
occupying the senate confirmation
hearing room and pro-abortion protesters
being dragged out
of the senate judiciary committee it's
not a shock that planned parenthood
the organization responsible for
hundreds of thousands of abortions per
year
openly threatened senators in poetry
quote
roses are red violets are blue senators
vote no on kavanaugh or else we're
coming for you
national poetry day stop kavanaugh now
that's romance
abortion to the vast majority of the
political left is a sacrament
it's not merely a political issue it is
a defining
character issue if you are pro-abortion
you are a good
generous decent person who values women
if you are pro-life
you are an evil repressive nasty person
who wants to control women's bodies
it's that view that leads to incidents
like this one in which a pro-life
advocate was kicked in the face
by a pro-abortion nutcase this week it's
a baby
if someone was raped and she gave birth
and she decided to kill her
three-year-old child
the pro-abortion movement suggests that
pro-lifers are extreme
in reality the extreme position on
abortion is held by the democratic party
their platform calls for legal abortion
all the way
until point of birth but pro-abortion
extremists get away with their rhetoric
because they use
euphemistic language to describe what
exactly abortion is
in fact the word abortion is itself a
euphemism
the procedure of abortion isn't an
anodyne polit removal
it involves doing terminal violence to
an unborn child
ignoring that fact allows abortion
advocates to avoid looking reality
directly in the face
so for just a few moments let's look
reality in the face
this is a picture of a 19 week old baby
this is a human child
this is not a ball of goo this is not a
cluster of cells
in january 44 democrats in the united
states senate
voted not to protect the rights of
babies older than this unborn child
only three democrats joe manchin joe
donnelly and bob casey
voted to protect children at 20 weeks
only two republicans voted against such
protection
susan collins and lisa murkowski take a
good look at that baby
that is a human being with zero rights
according to the mainstream of the
democratic party
and human life doesn't begin at 20 weeks
this is a picture of a baby
at 12 weeks barely three months you can
see this baby
with his hands near his chest this is
not a cluster of cells
this is not a ball of goo his genitalia
have already been formed
his liver and spleen produce red blood
cells this is an unborn
human being not a single federally
elected democrat would vote
for an abortion ban that would protect
this baby's life
and life doesn't begin at 14 weeks this
is a picture of an unborn human being at
eight weeks
you can identify the head of this unborn
human you can see where the small buds
are forming for arms and legs but guess
what life doesn't begin at eight weeks
either
it begins at fertilization when a new
human life is formed
a new human being with its own dna this
human being
is not its mother it is not its father
it is not a polyp
if we found a human embryo on another
planet the headlines would rightly
scream
human life found on mars human life is a
continuous process of growth
from the moment of fertilization onward
abortion is the killing of this human
life
the later the abortion takes place the
more brutal the procedure but
no matter the brutality of the procedure
it is obvious
that abortion is not some mere optional
surgery to be performed for convenience
and it's even more obvious that those
who want to protect the lives of the
unborn
aren't trying to control women's bodies
those who cherish abortion are trying to
control
and dismember the bodies of the unborn
think about that next time you see a
radical feminist
in a handmaid's tale outfit suggesting
that you'd better respect her right to
carve apart an unborn baby in the womb
or you're some sort of fascist no more
euphemisms